today South Park says goodbye to mr.
Hankey the longtime union of this town
and the holiday figure is over for good
we should all feel pretty great about
ourselves give ourselves a little nice
pat on the back as we as a society
continue to try and sweep away all the
poop well I guess this is goodbye
it sure has been swing no goodbyes
Hankey you just need to go we've already
called you a pooper oh you mean lift
okay goodbye everyone hope I brought a
few smiles and a few laughs into your
hearts goodbye mr. Hankey
[Music]
where will he go he'll have to find a
place that accepts racist awful beings
like him there are still places out
there who don't care about bigotry and
hate welcome my friend please rest your
weary feet and make yourself at home
yeah
you